이번에 규제
완화를 통해서 좀 그런
서울의 초고층 빌딩들이 좀 많이
생겨나고 우리 대한민국 서울에도
누구나 다 알만한 이런 세계적인
빌딩들이 많이 생겨났으면 하는
말입니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은 최근에 좀 좋은 뉴스가
있어서 좀 영상을 찍게 됐는데 최근에
나온 뉴스 중에
여의도에
용적률을 완화해 주겠다는
기사가 좀 많이 나갔습니다 오세훈
시장에
여의도에 이제 용적률을
완화하겠다
원래 기존에 그 여의도가
일반상업지역이었는데 이거를
중심상업지로 바꾸겠다 중심상업지로
바꾸면 용적률이 무려 1000%입니다
1000%
에다가 만약에 이제 인센티브까지
받으면
1,200%까지 이제 올릴 수 있어요
기존의 저희가 생각했던 그런
건물들보다 더 높게 그러니까 지금
파크원이 제일 높은데
파크원 높이가 333m
정도 되거든요 근데 그거보다
높은
초고층 빌딩들이
여의도에 많이
생겨날 것 같습니다 저 개인적으로는
이런 규제 완화에 있어서 좋은
정책이라고 저는 생각이 들고 얼마
전에 이제 뉴욕에 갔을 때도 초고층
빌딩들이 워낙 많잖아요 그래서 되게
유명한 건물들 중에 이렇게 전망대가
되게 멋있는 곳들이 많더라구요 그런
되게 멋진 전망대들이 되게 많아서
부러웠는데 근데 우리나라는 아무래도
좀 되게 한정적이잖아요 뭐 예를
들어서 롯데타워라든지 뭐
63빌딩이라든지 몇몇 군데 없거든요
이번에 만약에 여의도가 개발이 되면
그런 멋진 전망대들이 좀 많이 있지
않을까 뭔가
외국인이 왔을 때도 그런 우리나라의
좀 이런
격이 좀 올라갈 것 같아요 그런
뭔가 초고층 빌딩들이 많이 생겨나면
저는 이번에 뭐 이런 규제 완화가
되게 잘한 정책이라고 생각이 되고
규제할 때는 규제하더라도 좀
풀어질 땐 좀 풀어줬으면 좋겠어요
앞으로 이런 규제 완화들이 좀 많이
나왔으면 좋겠습니다
아무래도 그 높이에 대해서 좀 감이
안 오실 수가 있어요네 그래서 예를
들자면
초고층 빌딩들을 제가 좀 비교를
하자면
뉴욕의 엠파이어 스테이트 빌딩이
높이가 한 380m 정도 됩니다네
근데
엠파이어 스테이트 빌딩 정도 되는
높이의 건물들이
여의도에 좀 많이 생겨날 것으로 좀
예상이 되고 지금 우리나라 기준으로
lct가 무려 높이가
411m예요
굉장히 높습니다 그래서
nct가
우리나라에서 두 번째로 높은
빌딩입니다 첫 번째는 당연히 이제
롯데타워고
롯데타워는 높이가 한 554m
123층이죠 그래서
롯데월드타워는
뉴욕의 제일 높은 빌딩인 그
월드트레이드 센터보다 더 높습니다
롯데타워가 여러분들 진짜 세계에서
다섯 번째로 높은 빌딩이잖아요 그래서
자부심을 충분히 가지셔도 좋을 것
같아요 최근에는 저기 한전 부지를
롯데월드 타워보다 더
느껴지겠다라고 해서 아마 한 560m
70m 정도 될 텐데
롯데월드타워보다 좀 높게 짓겠다고
했는데 아무래도 좀 여러 문제들
때문에 비용이나 이슈들 때문에 그거를
좀
층수를 낮춰서
차라리 한 두세 개동으로 나눠서
짓겠다라는 그런 계획이 좀
변경되었는데 저 개인적으로는 좀
아쉽습니다 그래서 세계에서 제일 높은
빌딩을 우리 건설사에서 지웠잖아요
브로치 할리파를 우리 건설사에서
지었는데 그걸 이제 좀 한국에
지었으면 좋겠습니다 이번에 규제
완화를 통해서 좀 그런
서울의 초고층 빌딩들이 좀 많이
생겨나고 저희가 뭐 예를 들면
홍콩이나
싱가포르나 이런데 가면은
초고층 빌딩들이 워낙 많잖아요 우리
대한민국 서울에도 누구나 다 알만한
이런 세계적인 빌딩들이 많이
생겨났으면 하는 말입니다 오늘 영상은
여기까지 준비했고요
앞으로 좀 여의도가 변화되는 모습
그리고 이제 뭔가 규제 완화가 됐을
때 좀 어떻게 변화하는 지 좀 앞으로
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같고 만약에 그런
초고층 빌딩들이 많이 생겨나면
아무래도 좀 공급이 많아지겠죠 공급이
많아지는데 만약에 그렇게 공급이 좀
많이 풀렸을 때
시장이 좀 어떻게
변하는지 그런 것도 좀
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다